et donc c'est avec vous c'est une
Charles on en parlait en début
d'émission le chef de l'État s'est
exprimé hier à 20h trois jours après la
promulgation de la réforme des retraites
tout à fait une allocution de 13 minutes
dans laquelle Emmanuel Macron revient
d'abord logiquement sur la réforme des
retraites une réforme nécessaire pour le
président qui regrette néanmoins
l'absence de consensus il souhaite
maintenant tourner la page et face à la
colère de cette dernière moelle c'est
donner 100 jours pour mener un plan
d'apaisement et d'actions autour de
trois chantiers prioritaires le premier
consacré au travail il sera notamment
question de revenus de conditions de
travail de carrière le deuxième concerne
la justice avec l'annonce par exemple de
la création de 200 nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie enfin le chef de l'État
entend travailler sur le progrès
notamment sur des sujets liés à
l'éducation et la santé il a donné
rendez-vous aux Français le 14 juillet
pour un premier bilan on écoute les
réactions de plusieurs élus c'était une
allocution nécessaire après tout ce
débat autour de la réforme des retraites
qui a été un débat long important aussi
pour
concitoyens mais aussi montrer que en
dehors de cette réforme des retraites il
y avait d'autres projets qu'on comptait
mener et qui permettait aussi de
poursuivre la transformation du pays
quand on arrive à travailler ensemble
maintenant la main on arrive à des bons
résultats présidents à rappeler hier les
résultats notamment économiques du pays
qui fait qu'on a jamais créé autant
d'emplois j'aimerai ouvert autant de
sites industriels qu'on a des pays le
plus attractif d'Europe et tout ça c'est
grâce aussi au travail de tous pas de
surprise il y avait beaucoup de
condescendance et de mépris dans
l'intervention du président de la
République qui a décrété qu'on passait à
autre chose sauf que les Françaises et
les Français ne veulent pas passer à
autre chose et que le sujet de cette
réforme des retraites il reste entier et
que la volonté d'abrogation de cette
réforme désormais promulguée reste
entier donc c'est pas au président de la
République qui n'est que président de la
République de choisir ce que les gens
ont dans la tête je pense que les
Français avaient assez peu d'attente et
répondre la colère qui est palpable
clairement dans nos rues par un circulé
il y a rien à voir c'est assumer c'est
comme ça le déva est fini et d'une
extrême violence en fait ça ne rajoute
que de la violence à la violence qui est
existe déjà dans notre quotidien et je
pense que ça ne fait que bah acter la
déconnexion d'un président qui regarde
mais alors qui regarde vers quelle
direction